all rise please for the channel and to
basically thank you
sorry cheaper managing director letting
you go to sleep please remain upstanding
for prayers
good evening counselors good evening
members of the public would you join me
as we pray
gracious and loving God we come tonight
with many concerns father we look at a
nation and some things seem beyond our
control and indeed they are but they're
not beyond yours Lord we commit all of
our planning and as a governments to you
and Lord tonight there are some things
that are under our control so it will
help us to put aside the bigger picture
and to concentrate on our communities to
concentrate on those things that we have
some sort of control and influence over
would you give us wisdom would you give
us discernment would you give us a
listening ear to one another and a
listening ear to you gracious lord in
all that is discussed and debated this
evening we pray that you would be Lord
and that you would be sovereign and your
presence would be here with us tonight
we ask in your neighbor Lord we pray
please be seated Memphis
good evening to you all
its members opposition members of the
public a special special welcome and to
our newest member
this is councillor sorry mrs. Daniel
Belton member for Swain Parker right
I shall take item one of the agenda
apologies for instance which is in the
obvious before council Missy soy sir mr.
boy kallu I owned it and mrs. Christine
Mason are there any others thank you
thank you
this very ciose
a lot of safety members we take item 2
of the meat of the agenda and it's about
hilde in the 16th of july 2019 can i
scan these besides to correct records of
moving team members 93 declarations of
interest any declarations of interest
thank you fighting for announcements
from the chairman leader of head or paid
service I would simply like to announce
that I've had a number of occasions that
I show once they don't want to go
through them but if any members have any
interesting without details or any
engaging engagement so that I go to I'll
be happy to get them further information
but I'd like to remind members of two
events one my civic service we held on
the 18th of December 2019 Trinity Church
and the Civic dinner we held it along on
the 6th of March 2020 hope to see as
many of you there as possible
item 5 of you general public questions
member beckandbill notice item 6
business and the last council meeting
item seven to another minutes of
executive and committee meetings on page
7.1 agenda
are they no team members thank you by
some men 8lb desert city report from the
executive and committees on the
responses to the questions before while
members can be founded a report that has
now been circulated to all members of
the council it was agreed that the
review committee the formal working
groups consider the requirements for the
new waste and recycling contracts taking
into account the effects they would have
on the council's carbon footprint and
spring forward recommendations for the
procurement process to council it was
also agreed that the review committee
will receive a report from the 10 degree
options for the street cleaning
cleansing service in February 2020 it is
clear that in order to carry out a
successful review of this item the
assistance of professionals will be
required and therefore the review
committee recommends to council the
budget
they can account for 32 members agree
the recommendations on page 8.1 or 3 of
the report with a budget of $40,000 war
for consultancy 2 assists with the
through procurement processing to help
inform the working group agreed thank
you
now come to item 8 2 of the agenda and
that's the report of the review
committee on the regulation of
investigative powers members will have
seen the attached report with the
recommendation by the review committee
as existing members and some new members
and this is an annual update that comes
before the review committee wise details
of annual usage along with any changes
to personnel mentioned to the policy
this time around it was only changes to
personal defending rooms have been
questions could be asked them to the
board the reason most assistant director
acuity houses here team in I'm sure that
the reader won't want any questions
the following subject do agree the
recommendation on page 8.32 of the
report the updated planning enforcement
that has set out in the appendix to the
opposite of all is subject to the
members requested by the review
committee to be adopted very
and I'll take place before the planning
policy subcommittee Thank You chairman
this members would have seen there are
two items for consideration by counsel
one is in relation to the statement of
community involvement update 2019 data
protection and neighborhood playing I
fully endorse the recommendations made
in relation to this item German with one
possible conclusion if this may be
considered by the council in future
towards the end of section at 1.3 it
reverses reverses the statement of
community involvement did not provide
clarity around who should make the
determination myrrh suggests German that
in between and somewhere on the line be
registered future notice in future of
greater clarification should be given
and made available as to where this
responsibility lies there's a number of
areas where it says you know noted or
passed not part of this group we believe
that that should computer be added into
this statement so it becomes a more open
report but apart from that chairman the
rest area thought fully recommend it for
council
[Music]
amendment there are two recommendations
first is on page 8.1 before they put
forward got one of the court do men's
agree the following recommendation okay
I've got the revised statement of
community involvement sent out an
appendix
I had notice accommodation feedback
report set out in Appendix B remembers
really great the second is on page April
should've integrated follow
recommendation that the Essex coast
recreational disturbance of ordinance
education strategy supplemented planning
document the rams SDPD 2019 a text at
appendix 6 SC be consulted on for a
period of six weeks
another group members reported position
now i to ten we came to deliver on the
work of the executive
Specter this is the second ordinary
house meeting of the 2019-20 music music
all year I would like to welcome all
members in particular councillor van der
welt'
do I dare to since the meeting on the
16th of July if deaf people met twice
during which consideration
considerations include noting that the
quarter one 2019-20 revenue budget the
capital position along with the latest
position of the council's key
performance indicators agreement to
produce for an external technical
advisor and of humans or the new letter
contract from 1st of April 2022 no to
the report of the assistant director
legal and Democratic Democratic on
contract Morrison for 2018-19 along with
the fact that the council has been right
a second nationally and first regionally
for waste collection service proving
reservations to the composition and
delivery of the field project subject to
the entrance being free for the public
to attend the big event agreement of the
disposal of the freehold of land of
London Road Rainey for the value of
three hundred thousand pounds to
sanctuary housing one of the matters
that mike says dear colleagues and I
have been dealing with includes
approving a change to rough the district
council
procedures in determining is
sustainability of hackney carriage and
or private prior licensee as
to change from submitting a paper DBS
application to using Essex County
Council's the electronic GPS system to
change our supplier of conducting for
DVLA checks to formally recognize and
adopt the use of the guidance on
determining the suitability of
applicants and licensees in the
hackneyed and private quiet roads the
green to enter into a lease for twelve
months to occupy three small shop units
being developed on the ground floor of
the former king's head public house West
with Rossford leased to the council on a
rent-free basis and our sublet to
meanwhile spaces that I see as part of
the NHC LG pilot scheme called open
doors which matches empty properties
with community groups and looking for
space suspending car park charges in all
their all counts of car parks on the
Saturday of June December night
Christmas as always chairman I will be
happy to take any questions from members
in respect to the work of the executive
and I'm sure these it my executive
colleagues will happy to contribute
where problems please
in Egypt just one question
around three disposals the free homeland
of London oh baby I know that the you've
got a evaluation or the property but
because of what it would be opened up I
would be surprised if the worth wasn't a
lot more than that I wonder if that was
actually explore German yes that was
fully explored and we had independent
that was with the bats and what they
agreed that the figure being offered was
redeemed evaluation thank you ability
thank you I have two questions if I may
a first question I'd like to know how
the place latest project is progressing
in the district and my second question
relates to the carbon neutral working
group given my business and involvement
in the green space I'm keen to who else
is taking part in their group
that question Jared I would suggest wolf
a cold environment best water okay miss
chairman
firstly I can sum up a list of the
Absinthe a carbon neutral committee
councilors Milnes Kelso Western
councillor canal council bill to
encapsulate Burton councillor McPherson
councillor Gooding helps reassure and
councillor couple that's all the other
members I have at the moment mr. Gough
the place basis I was very pleased
those Fridays work with the movement
wavering clay space and handed over to
the residence of the great night cream I
have some interesting pickers here the
roadway dream place mates cost the
council's 60,000 pounds of which 45,000
pounds of raised from a grant from an
inadvertent environmental trust
therefore it was a net cost of the
council wishes for to tight spaces the
great way to bring one and the the small
swing guards notional rub it on so that
cost us as a 15,000
rajat recreation ground alone is in
progress the cost of that expected me to
55,000 pounds I'm pleased to say that we
have received funding from series to the
mountain amounts of 45,000 so there's a
net cost layer of ten rainy we have been
foreclosed outstanding the project to
the cost of many small details at the
moment we were looking for bids on that
but has welcomed today I found out but
we have moments most unity is just
comfortable to walk Paul the hopeful
comments rate at which we are bidding
for close to five thousand the Big
Lottery Fund so this will be across the
55,000 hopefully there will only be a
necklace of ten thousand pounds I would
very much much take so mature thinking
would be their hard work and the support
other members thank you very much Thank
You counsel Williams yes yes
thank each other just like to ask a
question in relation to leading to
changes in licensing to do with any
character this Lima license also have an
interesting but it's in relation to
interchange from submitting operator
deviate application to using an online
system whether there were icicles
amendments had the opportunity to be
able to use Council of these facilities
to do this or are they expected to do
this on their own
in German and I would assume that that
would be a possibility but I will have
to confirm with officers and come back
in writing just to make sure
Thank You counselors Epson sits in
solitary housing check and I direct that
question to the e-portfolio communities
yes thank you a question can be short
we've seen a numbers near better
breakfasts and Anya let significantly
dropped in the last two years
who's the hard work of the housing
options team
in September as the council we have only
two households in bed and breakfast and
twelve households in 90 days in October
misspelled 2-0 households in better
breakfast and our new ninth house
households in 90 let's these are the
lowest figures that we've had in water
district since 2002 prevention work of
the team's case the success I'm pleased
to see we are continuing to meet the
needs of our residents
so my thanks again to have the housing
options take all the hard work I have
carried out in our district the
questions
but anything though I've got question
for the tool 504 a voice voice being
plans for the 2020 celebrations in
tradition
package ever thank you - counselor ft
for that question he was quite enough to
give me just a little bit of advance
notice so that I could do my homework
but discover 20/20 within the Rockford
district he's celebrating the rich
history and heritage of the community
where we all live amongst other things
next year the hundredth anniversary of
Lexington church built in 1020 by the
order of the king the five hundred and
fortieth anniversary of the original
rockford hall built around 1480 and home
to the boudin family the four hundred
and fortieth anniversary of the
commuting witch trials the 50th
anniversary of the opening of the rainy
windmill to the public now you
understand why I had researched my
history books 2020 also marks the 200th
anniversary of the launch of HMS Beagle
in 1820 which was one of the most famous
ships in history
so from navigating through the globe
Charles Darwin have her famous passenger
and Robert Fitzroy her captain of
synonymous with discovery in the fields
of science meteorology G and even space
exploration a chemist speaker was
decommissioned by the Royal Navy in 1845
and transferred to the Coast Guard's of
watch vessel station of pagglesham where
her remains are believed to be buried
the Beagle event as we're currently
calling it what we're actually looking
for shall we say a slightly more glitzy
name but the Beagle event organised by
rotary Council will be in two parts a
small opening ceremony for anxiety
guests to mark the completion of an
observation viewing gallery of policy
Island
a public event at the freight house over
the weekend xxx xxx person
2020 which will comprise various
attractions and activities I am pleased
to announce an impact the leader beat me
to it very slightly that this event will
be free to all families of the public as
we want to encourage families
irrespective of their financial
circumstances in the district to
celebrate and share in the rich heritage
of the area in which we all live
for more information can I suggest that
you do actually go on to block to the
council website where there is more
information about the discover it
discover 2020 thank you thank you Thank
You chairman listening pulling up on the
councillor Pelton and Counsell Williams
comments about the review committee
carbon-neutral working party well it
said disappointing that there appears to
be no members of the Green Party who
want to support this project and just
might have point Jim thank you for
making that point other questions
in that case you're going to buy some 11
into the motion or notice we have one
motion on notice proposed by councillor
Wilkinson the motion is to establish a
working group conduct a feasibility
study into the installation of CCTV
across the district thank you show sorry
Mavis forgive me I think I'll put it
take a little longer than I need to or
otherwise we're done because I need to
split operations with two cars first of
all Reddy's describes what this motion
is about and secondly some of you will
be slightly confused as to why even
appears on the agenda this evening
because some of us have had a prior
conversation with the Guardian so first
of all what is it about the subjects of
CCTV is what I would call the meta
product the can that's been kicked
around this district for far too long no
one seems to know where the liability
sisters a secret district as it's
sitting there perishes well
CCTV is one tool as part of a crime and
disorder reproduction and crime
prevention Public Safety public
reassurance that liability is quite
clear to the crumbs so we're actors sits
with a local authority which is us not
the parish councils so the fact our
district has not got a fully functional
CCP CCTV system is in my opinion
outrageous when you consider we are the
only one in this area not to have a
local fund at one it is something which
I know has been discussed at various
levels for some period of time and for
whatever reasons I'm not gonna go into
it hasn't happened so my motion my
proposals before members tonight is I'm
not lying enough to come in here and say
hey dr. Cassidy's
I'm the new city TV sister because that
would be ridiculous that's not going to
happen overnight but what I do think we
do need to do and what we owe the
residents of this district is that we at
least research the options around CCTV
and therefore my proposal is to form a
working group and that working group is
to look at options I think conductor the
sense of feasibility study involving
aspects such as technology technology
moves on very quickly legislation rip is
not an issue because there are it's not
a code but tactical initiative gdpr
might be an issue locations and these
assessments etc etc there a lot of
things that the and funding of course a
big one as well now these things are not
going to get answered overnight so we
need a working river to research door
and report back to full council whether
with it with options as to how we can
move forward for the benefit of this
district in essence for members that's
what the motion is about it's obviously
quite longer to documents are submitted
which hope in hope be able Towe chance
to see notes to go through the whole
thing very briefly to explain the
history as to where we are and what's
forced me to be standing where I am
right now on the 25th of May this year I
did what I thought was the correct
process what starts the correct process
for this and I contact the portfolio
holder responsible for this area
business comes to the web by email asked
him to agree with me that as a council
we need to look into this his reply was
like long-winded but essentially that no
we don't it doesn't sit with us he
doesn't think it sits with us various
members of the public have also
contacted when the same subjects a gain
of a similar answer and he doesn't agree
with it fair enough
so I decided to formulate a motion to
bring the full council at our last
meeting the 16th of July I had the
courtesy to speak to various members of
the administrative leadership before the
meeting to explain what the motion was
about
on board I was advised that the best
course of action would be to send this
item to review and that was explained to
me and I thought fair enough I was told
that members on the other side of the
chamber would not vote for it but the
Senate said it's a review which I did so
on or the 16th of July I was armed with
the paper copy of the motion which I
hand it to the chairman of few committee
counsel burden whose notice next to me
and it's who explained what my motion
was bounced and I'd be in touch
I then contact them again on 27th of
July did not receive a reply there was
then an article a after some holidays in
the fo newspaper where it counts the
birth I'm talking about how the review
committee on the district council was
looking at CCTV so again my contact
stillman asked if that was a case no
reply I then looked at the agenda for
the review committee on the 3rd of
September no mention of CCTV at all in
the area and target work plan and the
work plan actually details work going
through to August 2020 with no mention
of CCTV strangely enough the carbon
neutrality motion that was also
discussed at the 16 July meeting was on
there as we know there's now a working
group so I contacted Council both again
to which I didn't get a reply I look to
the next review committee agenda which
was going on the 8th of October sadly
again members there was no mentions on
this so it's quite clear that there is a
degree of apathy here around
CCTV and I don't understand why I don't
know what the resistance is about it but
we cannot drive up here was any more so
I have decided to bring this back before
full council now and say I have tried I
oppose its portfolio holder I have
spoken to a few I have done exactly what
I've been advised to do and it is not
worked
so therefore chairman with respect I
place ask members to allow us to for
working group so that we can look at
this properly for the benefit of the
residents
[Applause]
Beks chairman I'd like to propose a
amendment to the motion which I only
broadly need a green pool and I read out
by members to set up a portfolio holder
working party of five members including
the portfolio holder for community to
establish Rockford District Council's
responsibility if any under the crime
and disorder Act 1988 and if necessary
conduct a benefit and feasibility study
and make recommendations to portfolio
holder for the community into the
possibility possible installation cost
and funding sources a CCTV across the
district taking evidence from parishes
Town Council police and our any other
interesting organizations for the
portfolio holder for the community to
make a recommendation to this council in
nine months chairman I do have some
copies of this amendment
really cancer steps we have a second
Thank You chairman and I do second that
with pleasure
and it's very clear that residents have
concerns in respect of antisocial
behavior that's not a secret
therefore I support that the working
party investigate all options whether it
can be funded a lot there's another
matter
that's an issue for the group to take
forward
thank you check it counselor
we didn't even go like a couple of the
amendment to the motion faces so they
Canada
I shall adjourn the meeting for five
minutes so that people can study the
amendment to the motion
is anybody asked what's a puppy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
members
for example
- Stanley there please the working party
the five members of the working party
should they should this get passed to
investigate my I ask that the
independent counselor who has book mr.
forecastle to be involved with
networking party please slip to you know
and yes I had already discussed that to
the portfolio holder and he will be
happy to make that offer to the
Mississippi
absolutely
Thank You chairman and thank our center
and I would like to publicly thank
accounts of Steptoe and councillor broke
some story about this list as well for
the courtesy of their to me see as
amendment in advance this meeting which
I don't know it might be extraordinary
but thank you anyway
it does raise various questions as I
explain concepts very long if I make a
chairman I just like to pose because he
has confuse me very slightly it doesn't
surprise me but it does confuse me I
just like to ask if I'm a councillor web
why is it that's you've changed mind
then
have you changed your mind because you
are now saying that you want people to
run this I said I suspect that you all
in favor of it so bearing in mind it was
something you work at favor thought of
five months ago
have you changed - oh boy and I suppose
the only way I could describe this is
that my feelings when I sit when I about
this is if we didn't have somebody well
in this group who doesn't believe in
something this is akin to Teresa makes
sorting out Britain and believing it but
I'm using it so I need to get some
reassurance really from cast away for
the benefit of the residents actually
this is something he does believe in and
it's going to take on board whole parts
of it thank you
are you happy - yes I'm happy to explore
it's absolutely right somebody point I
do have some concerns or some issues to
be based in a report but I'm happy to
explore that and obviously happy working
parties fall into your pockets we
thought of that between two integral
part of that absolutely this is a chance
to review something a bit more
just to have a little bit more
reassurance chairman yes I will be
keeping a very close eye on the working
party as part of the just like to ask
the portfolio hunger and in relation to
the makeup is it something that he will
to nominate the
[Music]
- acceptor
German yes it will be up to the
portfolio holder himself if we applied
the program to rule this which we don't
will aren't required to do so in this
case it would mean for members of the
Conservatives on one other so it would
be closely around that but it will be
for portfolio home to discuss and find
which which members are going to the
best to serve on and working party and
that might be across party but we'll
have to have a vote discussions on that
outside of this mega game and just on
that point actually in my motion I do
not reference the fact that I requested
this is not politicized
my guess is going to be it's going to be
under the portfolio governor however I
think personally I'm sure that he was
Green which M is that isn't this more
beneficial that rather that it's pro
rata or source whatever ratio to chose
another port but on the elation should
be geographically represents different
geographically representative and I
think within the district because what
it's not right is to have a number of
cancers in one area because each
district each area this district needs
to be represented on that
German again I've already had
discussions with the portfolio holder
along those lines there are some of the
members aren't here this evening
particularly from the agent of the
district we understand normal practice
like gem with other words and parties
and subcommittees that we have set up we
have had correspondence from members of
other parties that have asked that the
Partridge be applied with them Anessa
Cerie do so hence the reason for me
working along those lines but catholic
ways for it no we don't need to apply it
ok any other questions
I'm concerned slightly by the wording
around establishing a brush with
district councils responsibility if any
under the crime and disorder Act of 1988
is someone with the legal background the
legal qualifications no best place to
determine out rather than a work make
sure that guess this whole point to put
it in there is that the working party
content evidence from legal advisors
there are legal advisors and others if
you so wishes as to exactly how that
sits with the council thank you I wasn't
quite sure it was still talking to this
amendment they seem to be just general
questions and answers now so I just want
to make it clear or just confirmation
that in the report is reference to
interesting part of their relationship
Democratic so once this is done this
community society is on working debating
the amendment to the motion well I think
once the amendment has been agreed which
I think it was beers the questions that
I thought becoming relevant and they are
with regards to the review committees
this chairman if the if the amendment is
agreed then it will take you outside of
your question if I could just add to
that of course once once it's all done
the review committee mr. cordovan if he
wishes
that's delicious any other questions in
members no one else is indicating I
would not take a sharp ends of the
amendment which of the motion is those
in favor
there's a case
two uniformed
what that is you cost Thank You Memphis
and we shall now go back to repeat then
there to agree the substantive motion
which is the emotion put forward by
chemists oh yes please
to set up portfolios moment of working
carbonate that does the amendments the
suspense motion was put forward on it
the amendment to the motion is known as
successive motion the governor's agenda
set up a portfolio holder working party
of five members including the portfolio
of community to establish lots of
District Council's responsibility if any
under the crime and disorder Act to 1998
and if necessary conduct a benefit and
feasibility study and make
recommendations of portfolio community
into the possible installation cost and
funding sources for CCTV across the
district taking evidence from parishes
town parishes tell council police and
any other interested organizations and
for the portfolio holder for community
to make recommend a recommendation to
this council within nine months
and that can either have a show of head
space for those in favor that what is
the other substantive motion one two
three five six seven eight nine ten
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
sixteen seventeen eighteen nineteen
Twenty twenty one twenty two twenty four
five six oh seven twenty eight twenty
one thirty thirty one thirty games
that's awesome Thank You members to to
trade allocation of seats on committees
[Music]
it's following the political position of
the council following the by-election in
the swing Park engagement on the 12th
simplicity should be reflected in the
allocation of seats on the councillors
committees and subcommittees appendix 1
to item 12 which is set out at pages of
twelve point four to twelve point five
shows seat allocations based on the
current composition in accordance with
the pro rata world please note that the
percentages for the conservative and
little Democrat groups they were don't
reference in the table Harris on page
twelve point five should be identical to
those on twelve report or the report 669
point two three zero eight percent of
conservative group and seven point six
nine to three percent for the Liberal
Democratic Chairman the provirus people
who set out on both pages 12 over 4 is
1.5 of the reports have been calculated
using those correct post by-election
percentages councils also endorse a
constitution other committees
some PC and said I'll be any fortune
he said approved
yes the planning policy subcommittee is
actually included in the calculations
it's just setting the sample table to
appear because of subcommittees
aesthetic reasons I can assure you the
calculations are correct even if we
added a total together 84 seats and six
seats make it so naughty the
calculations to work out as they are on
both clock at four and twelve point five
of the appendix
it's next challenge just like like to
clarify in regards to the licensing
appeals committee I believe there are 15
seats and currently there are never
names list so I know correct in assuming
that there are currently chairman Kuk
leaders having devoted to nominates the
council speakers and the subcommittee
addendum one item 12 copies of which
have been distributed to you this
evening
commencing on 12 to 11 my name is who
page 12 and 13 says our membership
committees and subcommittees that
they're with me Thank You people
denominations that be receiving office
members we don't have 11 nominations
from vacancies to 15 seats on the nice
and significance community it should be
noted as set out on page 12 point well
with the addendum according to the
program's rules
there should be one nomination seat for
both the Liberal Democrats and much of
District residents after that the green
given Democrat a bunch of District
residents would can each nominated one
of the two remaining vacant seats the
report sets out at paragraph 3.5 on 12
on page 12 on to the process to be
followed if after three weeks one today
those please produce plans to express
their own instead of those
so members can we please agree to
endorse a nomination set up a new dental
one a pages 12 way learn to talk
business
13:51 members of Metis of the executive
that's a step back chairman
one of the things I first took the but I
wanted to make things more inclusive and
one of the things that I'm looking to do
is be part of the executive committee
minute council to make it more inclusive
but for members to that aren't members
of the executive to be able to ask
parents at the executive meetings on
with regards to the agenda for the
executive members of the public was to
have a question asked at the executive
they came and that hoped that they would
have to go through their ward councillor
or any other councillors so hopefully
chairman that that will make it a little
bit more inclusive the details and the
rules are laid out within the report and
there will have to be one or two changes
within the Constitution itself to make
that accommodation focus but I'm happy
to take any questions
the question should can susceptor yes a
little bit
thank you and thank you well cancer
steps are first a bit of this a positive
step forward can I just ask if it's not
going to be done and that's a bit of
information be made public to the public
so that everybody know is particularly
with reference to remember the public
where the last question has to go
through the counselor they need to know
they can actually now ask pressures of
the executive I think that's quite
important topic tonight which was
something you got in hand
yes German there will be some publicity
around that particular point certainly
as far as all the members are concerned
and I believe it will be on our website
and various other places as well so I
guess that has been taken to do members
then agree the recommendation on page 13
points two of the reports Thank You
members of the final item my pleasure